we think about conventional activities
to expand thematic and conceptual
exploration so the traditional ways or
maybe more conventional agent might
think about art education or learning
studio practices sculpture working with
clay working with wood working with
paint or drawing practices those are
fine if we want to develop a set of
skills but what about thinking about
concepts and themes and issues well you
might as well get started and do some of
that now so we're gonna make a little
transition I'm gonna set up a still-life
over here and we're going to do some
drawing I don't the range of ways in
which people draw is perfectly
acceptable perfectly acceptable so if
you're a concern that you it's tough for
you to draw a conclusion or draw a
straight line don't be concerned by that
it's the process that we're interested
in not the visual representation we have
the three chairs in the center with your
marker I would like you to to draw what
you see and you can draw it on this
paper the way that it makes sense to you
if you want to draw it as large as you
can that's great if you want to draw it
smaller that's fine but here's our still
if these three chairs kind of sitting in
relationship to each other will take
about eight to ten minutes to draw this
oh but there's one thing this is my is
one more thing you'll draw for thirty
seconds at a time and then after your 30
seconds is over I have another task for
you okay so you're gonna draw the chairs
for 30 seconds and then I'll give you
another step to continue your drawing
got it alright so when you ready set go
it's not a race I you just go time
starts now
[Applause]
try to put in as much information as you
can all right stop stop now what you're
gonna have to do is slide back and your
chair slide back a little bit and then
stand up and then move one drawing to
the left so now you're standing in front
of somebody else's drawing to the left
okay standing prints the next pert near
that next drawing all right now keep
drawing continue the drawing that this
other person has started go
all right stop move did you learn
something about drawing from other
people's drawings like as you went
through it nice at times oh there was
some things happening at this new
drawing that you're sitting at that you
hadn't thought about that maybe he tried
to replicate or he tried to avoid my
attitude toward what I was doing changed
rather markedly in different parts of
the circle so I started out with trying
to take the assignment literally and I
assumed that somebody else that's their
representation of that it's my job to
come to Edie to complete their
representation but about over there by
that time since I couldn't figure their
representation relative to what I was
looking at that I finally decided well I
could contribute something to this but
it isn't their representation that I'm
helping to finish I'll just focus on
adding solid services to ones that don't
have solid services because clearly
there's some solid services so as I
moved along I was making sure I added
something but I wasn't any longer trying
to complete what the message was that
the previous person that the original
person had left but the time I got
thought of over there I realized people
were adding things that were extraneous
to the literal assignment and that's
sort of oh I see this is just a picture
now this is no longer a still life that
has to be represented now there's people
just making it into a picture they're
putting things that are not there in the
picture oh okay that's fun and so now I
realized that the assignment had changed
or I had my conception of it had
radically altered and then by the time I
get back to my own I recognize nothing
and I said okay well I can barely find
what I started with there's layers of
what other people produce but my sense
of what I was doing changed as there
were
Changez imposed by many people before me
getting to the picture mad that's a
wonderful what I want to transition to
the next drawing task but inherent in
what everyone was saying could be
applied to other tasks other subjects
imagine if we didn't have a set of
chairs there well imagine if there was a
person there instead of drawing with
lines we were drawing with the questions
we were asking this person who had never
met before or maybe we passed this
person numerous times like we passed
these chairs all the time these chairs
are just in the room but now we put them
in a space of of inquiry oh now I have
to look I've learned some things about
these chairs in this circle that I
didn't realize about the chairs before
just by the act of mark-making so what
if we put a person there someone we may
pass on the street every day and we just
we stopped instead of drawing them we
could draw them what if we asked
questions of them what if each mark that
we're making is some form of a question
that we're asking how much more would we
learn about that person just by talking
to that the idea here will be that we'll
still use the chairs and we're still
building on this premise of learning
from each other's drawings but now
instead of us all drawing and moving to
each other's drawings one person will
take the drawing implement and you will
be connected fixed to that drawing
implement in other words you're an
extension of that drawing implement and
your partner has to find a way to use
you the drawing implement to draw the
chairs all you're doing drawing
implement is holding the marker the
person who is your partner is using they
might have to hold your hand or your
elbow or your shoulder or shoulder and
wrist that's what I'm saying you need to
have the permission of the other person
and then they're going to draw what they
see they're going to draw the chairs
using you and the marker as the
implement and you're they implement
you're kind of in it to see
how this drawing turns out so some of
the words I'm hearing that to me work in
tandem with this notion of themes or
concepts responsibilities influence
there's some notion of liberation in
what you said over there right
cooperation so these are themes or
concepts that might be important to many
disciplines or many discourses but one
way we might get to it could be doing an
activity like this even though this
activity is could also be taken very
literally in terms of formal approach
--is to revise and enhance the way
people render in through drawings to
render realistically the objects that
they're seeing but there's also
conceptual piece here that we don't want
to miss
you